so Super Bowl ads are 8 million bucks
each now the big question is is it worth
it and what can you learn from them as a
business to improve your advertising I'm
Alex rosi I acquisition. comom I've run
millions of dollars of ads and today I'm
going to tear up the ads at the Super
Bowl across 6 key factors to determine
whether it was a touchdown or fumble
isn't that cute cute little analogy
touch down or fumo first up Google take
it away so at my last job I was working
across several different groups
um you know what let me practice that
one again okay when you're ready tell me
about the job that taught you the
most
okay well it was a role where I learned
to take constructive criticism I think
she like oh no doesn't like it okay I
got pretty used to you know working long
hours with a small team I got very
comfortable uh multitasking and I had to
become really
organized not bad but try rephrasing
your answer to sound more confident
right right okay I was asked to make a
lot of quick decisions and do a lot of
negotiating one more
book talk about your experiences working
with others oh Dad well I'm at my best
when I'm collaborating if it's for the
team I'll do whatever it takes this job
description you shared mentions on the
job training well I am a fast
learner I don't always have all the
answers but to get the job done
gas no matter how long it
takes and I'm not afraid to admit when
I'm
wrong but most importantly I show up
every day no matter
what all right last question when it
comes to work what motivates you there
she
go I guess knowing that people can
depend on me
[Music]
and knowing I can depend on them
too that's a great answer sounds like
you're
[Music]
ready hey James thanks for joining us
it's good to see you all I've been
looking forward to
talking so real quick what we're going
to be ranking these on is did it grab
attention uh did it make you care did it
sell the dream did it create urgency did
it show social proof and most
importantly did it tell you what to do
next this ad I think was exceptional
honestly I think it was exceptional for
a number of reasons the first is that
they draw this really you know very
sentimental story arc was almost like
the up movie where you get the whole
love story in you know 2 minutes at in
the movie this was basically that just
done in like 30 seconds but they were
able to weave in product demonstration
and usage throughout the entire thing
which I think made it incredibly
compelling in terms of what to do next
at the end I mean they tell you about
the product but I think what they really
drive is uh sentiment uh with this ad
which is that I think a lot of people
would be like I resonate with any one or
many of those slides because either
you've been the kid you've been the
adult you've been the one for the job
they actually cut a lot of different
audiences by showing all these very
human experiences and they've done it
they did it super well in terms of proof
they're literally demonstrating in terms
of urgency I don't think it would be on
brand for them to create urgency so I
would knock them for that it's just very
direct response and so big picture the
Google G Gemini ad I think I'm moved to
s tier I think it was exceptional I
haven't seen the rest of the ads but I'm
I'm bullish on the start I know so ad
number two is ramp.com hey should we
pull saquin off the field right now to
submit his expenses you better not say
[Music]
yes switch your business to ramp.com so
this was a short ad obviously what is
this 15 seconds so they probably spent
four or 5 million for this ad instead of
the full 8 for 30 unless it was 8 for 15
somebody can fact check me anyways I
think the hook was contextual to the
audience that was watching which was a
football player right and so that made
sense question based hook around pain
fundamentals and I'm a big fan of this
and I think not a a lot of business
owners do this but it's demonstration
they start with a pain based hook of
what it's like to not have the product
and then they just immediately solve it
with having the product through
demonstration I mean if you're talking
about 15 seconds to get a point across I
think it was a pretty effective ad I
probably would have done more with the
end screen personally and I probably
would have said switch your business to
rather than have it just be audio main
reason is a lot of people are you know
watching TV from afar they don't have uh
you know subtitles on so I tend to be
over indexed on text personally but
that's just my own opinion I would put
that as an a I think it was a good ad so
ad three is booking.com let's run it
with hotels and vacation rentals
booking.com has something for everyone
she you got Boutique we we wee right
this way now we're talking what about
something more family friend L maybe a
resort with a water
park or somewhere less family friendly
yep one Vegas hotel for the bride to be
what if we hate everything we have free
cancellation find exactly what you're
booking for booking.com
booking personally not a huge fan of it
it felt super
tvisha TV but it felt like an old ad
like it was a new it's obviously it's a
new ad but like obviously the Muppet are
an old brand but it just felt like 2005
television that's just that's that was
my initial impression they tried to
demonstrate the use cases I think the
humor wasn't like super funny and so I
think I had a more difficult time of
being like Oh I'm this Avatar personally
and so I probably would have done this
at completely differently uh if it were
me I probably would put this I don't
know if I want to use up a d d all the
way I'll probably I'm going to put this
as a c put this as a c I didn't like
starting with booking.com that's what
the first thing you see is booking
I don't know what that is yet they hint
at some pain I had a harder time because
the cuts were Cuts were fast but weren't
explanatory like I didn't know where we
were going just felt super mid like
compare that to the Google ad it's like
like I what are we even talking about
like I feel like it's not even close so
ad number four from Doritos is made from
a fan contest I'm actually really pumped
to watch this one
aliens Det
come on
man Dorito Dorito yeah all right I like
this ad uh what's really interesting is
that there's no basically no words which
I find uh great so this is all like
creative if you want to think about from
that perspective if you think about
psychological triggers here though what
what they're showing is that something
super desired right not only that it's
that somebody would literally risk their
life in order to keep it but then they
they closed the loop at the end and
showed that it's actually like peace one
person sharing with another so as as
much as it's I don't know if it was
deliberate or not but there's actually a
lot of um kind of like human psychology
stuff that's kind of built into this I'm
a fan I wouldn't I mean this is very on
brand for Doritos which is just like
crazy bold right like it's almost like
they have a Red Bull brand but for chips
so kind of interesting there the way the
duritos did this is the way that I would
do this uh which is at the end of the
day like I'm going to I'm going to we're
going to spice up these ads and I'll
I'll break down some of the things that
I would have considered doing you can't
beat data and so like you might have an
opinion somebody else might have an
opinion but at the end of the day the
best ad that's on here is the one that
drove the most sales now obviously a big
part of that happens with uh past
history of brand and so some
advertisements have different objectives
right a lot of some ads might just be
purely branding they want to build
positive sentiment of uh positive
association between their product or
their company and you know the Target
demographic or audience some of them
just reinforcing the existing position
like Doritos is some of them are a
pre-ir response ad so I think it really
depends the objective but for here from
a data perspective if zillions of people
already submitted different ads and this
one got upvoted the most or shared the
most then you already know you have
almost like a pre-baked winner and so
like when I wrote the leads book which
is all about advertising one of the one
of the things that I break down in here
is if you see this on page
37 and all the way through I did
headline tests for the headline of this
book and so I could have talked to five
people and said hey do you like $100
million advertising or do you like $100
million uh leads or do you like milon
promotions you're like $1 million
marketing right I could have gone
through all of these different notations
but instead I just let the data talk
what they did was they let the data talk
and fundamentally who am I to say one
thing is better than another but this
was obviously the most viral ad that
they they were able to source and here's
the even more brilliant part it cost
them basically nothing they just let the
audience make it for them which is
basically crowdsourcing or advertising
which I'm a big fan of and one of the
great things about building communities
which you can check out at school.com so
they gave a million bucks for winning
but for most of these big ad agencies it
would cost them more than a million
dollars to to make the ad and not even
be sure if it's going to be good or not
here they got to spend a million dollars
to crowdsource from the best creators
out there that obviously love their
product and if a customer makes an ad
for your product they're going to know
it more intimately that anyone will at
some Ad Agency where there's a bunch of
you know tween trying to figure out like
whatever the hell they figure out um
this is people who actually use the
product and so also as another quick uh
side note you might not be the demo so
if you when I say demo I mean
demographic so like you might not be the
target so if some of these ads are like
I don't know if this really like ramp
might not have like if if you're a
business owner ramp makes sense if you
don't own a business you probably don't
care at all about ramp right and so
making sure that we're judging
appropriately based on whether we are
the avatar for the ad also carries
weight so I'm going to give this um I'm
going to give this an A so the next ad
is
Jeep longest thing we ever do is live
our
lives but life doesn't come with an
owner's
manual might have been nice huh but that
means we get to write our own
stories freedom is
yes or
no
or maybe freedom is for everybody but it
isn't free it's
earned there are real heroes in the
world but not the ones in the
[Music]
movies real heroes are humble they're
not driven by
pride pride is a terrible
driver freedom is the roar one man's
engine and the Silence of
anothers freedom is the ability to
inspire the most sacred thing in life
isn't the
path it's the freedom to choose it
you don't have to be friends with
someone to wave at him we won't always
agree on which way to
go but our differences can be our
strength so choose but Choose Wisely
choose what makes you happy my friends
my
family my work make me happy this Jeep
makes me happy even though my name is
that's my owner's manual how long was
his get out there write your own is that
whole thing I was like that was super
long did they run that whole thing so if
Jeep ran a 2minute ad or 2 and a half
minute ad then they spent whatever 8
Time 5 which is a lot of of eight time
fives right when you're counting in
millions okay what I want to do is
actually show you what happened in this
ad because this is uh this is branding
and now there there was such a clear
equation that they use that I want to
break it down for you so they said Jeep
equals Freedom this is literally as
clear as day Association as you can make
then they said freedom is stuff our demo
likes if you like these things you like
Jeep and then they just hit thing after
thing after thing after thing after
thing to be purposeful to curate the
associations that they wanted to make
with Jeep notice they didn't say Jeep
starting at 13 financed for 68 months
and 0% APR whatever they didn't do any
of that this was a pure brand-based ad
there's obviously product placement
inside of it which is fine we're trying
to reinforce the brand I would say that
they're very very specific about the
avatars that they're trying to attract
and so I would bet you that the things
that they chose in terms of the stuff
they liked are things that they know
from customer research cuz if you're
just drop $ 40 million on an ad or
whatever they spent the customer
research they did I'll bet you they
picked the words and things that they
knew their demo like now if you watch
this I can tell you that this is
probably not targeted at women I can
probably also tell you that this is
going to lean to a more conservative
crowd I can tell you this is probably
people who are more Pro military when
you're thinking about this like he said
Freedom isn't free that's more commonly
a a right leaning narrative they
probably know their Avatar is more right
leaning they know their Avatar and so
they made a clear equal sign in terms of
what they're about if you like Freedom
you'll like Jeep and freedom is all of
these things that you like so like Jeep
basically and I do think the little quip
at the end with Harrison Ford was nice
um about it being his last name a little
bit of a shot across the bow but
fundamentally this is pure brand I think
this is a good ad I wouldn't say it's
the Google ad I would say it's an a tier
was a good ad all right next ad is hin
and hers obesity is America's deadliest
epidemic this is America 74% of us are
overweight and obesity leads to half a
million deaths each year why you just
have to stop eating Jimmy this is
America something's broken and it's not
our bodies it's the system welcome to
weight loss in America like And
subscribe a60 billion industry that
feeds on our failure they're medications
that work but they're price for profits
not patients this is America this system
wasn't built to help us it was built to
keep us sick and stuck but not anymore
him and hers offers life-changing weight
loss medications they're affordable
doctor trusted and formulated in the USA
you get a treatment plan designed by a
doctor to fit your body goals and
lifestyle you deserve to feel great in
your body
this is the future of healthcare this is
him and hers join us in the fight for a
healthier America initial impression uh
it's definitely visually jarring
obviously because you've got a big
stomach that just flaps and you've got
weight it's so it's basically a very
fear-based hook what was interesting to
me is that I've never seen hims and hers
as healthc care which is what they said
so I don't know if they're trying to
shift their brand and that was kind of
the goal that they had with this
particular ad it did feel a little bit I
don't know if to say disingenuous but
basically they were like all these medic
medications are meant for profit and
then they're like take our medication
and so that felt very like pandering it
just I probably wouldn't have been that
strategy so by and large this is a
branding based ad but I think this
serves as a perfect ju deposition
between the Jeep ad which I think was a
really excellent ad from a branding
perspective and this ad which I don't
think hit the mark for me also I didn't
see any dream outcome the Jeep ad talks
about what people want they want freedom
and they they demonstrate Freedom
visually in a lot of you know
freedom-based occasions here I see a lot
of over people now maybe if you're an
overweight person you would say oh this
that is for me but I don't know how many
like they're thin and all of the people
who are taking their stuff are not
there's a lot of little things that I I
wasn't the biggest fan of but I think
they would want to also demonstrate that
like it works for people who are not
overweight but cuz they also do like
hair replacement I think they do they do
a bunch of other things besides weight
loss but maybe glp1 products are just
crushing it for them that being said I
to to me this was the worst ad I think
what was the one that we had at C tier
booking yeah I think this one's worse
than that um I'll put that as a d cuz
the the question we have to ask
ourselves is does an overweight person
let's just say that they're trying to
make themselves more accessible for you
know overweight people so then we asked
the question okay would it overweight
people like well they had a lot of stuff
they didn't like but they didn't show a
lot of stuff that they did and then they
also branded themselves as Healthcare
which maybe there's a strategy around
that but I think most overweight people
hate thinking about how they have health
care and like they're sick and fat and
all this stuff I will say I'm limited
cuz I've never been overweight and so I
don't know but yeah my initial
impression was not like Yay this is
really compelling all right ad seven is
on that's a slice oh Mr Roger Federer
why does it say q and C on your shoes
that's an o and n for on um hm well you
know Elma knows his alphabet and and
does definitely a Q and A C trust me
Elma it's it's on okay but you know Elmo
loves you Mr Roger Federer even if you
don't know your alphabet yet looks like
on right yeah
roer I can already tell you what my
score is on this one to me it's a c I'll
tell you why I think it's a c like I
would say the the one before this was I
had a bad aftertaste from the last ad
this one is just like it has nothing to
do with anything besides you have a
celebrity endorsement and they're just
talking about the letters of the name of
the company is this a branding ad right
so does it make associations that our
target audience like now they might like
Federer but the subject matter they're
talking about is just like the name of
the company and I think they made this
ad all about them rather than making all
about the customer and I think that's
where they missed so I think they just
forgot like rule number one is that like
no one cares about you they just care
about themselves and so I think they
they missed the mark there I would say
that it wasn't distasteful but I put it
as a c at eight Go Daddy let's rip it
actors we have the power to convince the
world we know what we're doing when in
fact we do
not I can make you believe I'm a
detective without ever stepping foot in
an actual crime scene
these symbols probably symbolize
something astronaut nope Houston I'm
observing some debris coming from
Uranus am I hardest rooll
yet small business
owner because I have no idea what I'm
doing the GoDaddy Arrow does using AI to
build a logo website and social content
so I can start Walton goggin's goggle
glasses because if your goggles ain't
goggin they don't belong on your Noggin
with GoDaddy Arrow it's like you know
what you're doing so this one I first
off I didn't really enjoy the call out
cuz it had actors as like almost the
call out so to me that like I'm like
well that immediately I'm like this
doesn't apply to me and then it takes
like 2third of the ad of just kind of
like demonstrating not knowing what
you're doing
but really not knowing where it's going
at all and then at the very end it's
like oh it's GoDaddy which is a hosting
site that can help you build your your
website with AI I would have just liked
real world business owners not knowing
how to do many other things and then
having this be the one thing that they
had figured out how to do right I would
have loved to seen like a a a before
after with this being like three four
five things in a row that a business
owner doesn't know how to do insert new
amazing thing the GoDaddy hosting and
then now they revisit the old things and
they can do 1 2 3 4 5 and then recap CTA
I think that would have been a far more
effective ad and I think the more
emotive those five things were the more
compelling the ad would have been right
so it's like how do I pay payroll like
that would be like an interesting thing
right now of course you're not going to
build a payroll website but there this
is me thinking off the top of my head
but like there are elements there that
you could probably take of business
owners like it' probably be like answer
my phone the email because they do all
of these things on the site so I
probably think through each of those
elements and just show before born after
I'm going to put this in the uh I'm
going to put this in the C category I
wasn't a huge fan as a as a business
owner I wasn't like super compelled also
random but like I don't know if small
business owners at all care about how
actors pretend to know what they're
doing and I don't know if you think
about this from repairing perspective
what they did was they compared actors
and small business owners and they
equated the two and I think most small
business owners probably wouldn't want
to call themselves actors now they might
have done some research to figure out
like look like you know what you're
doing and I'll bet you that phrase might
convert um but I think they might have
taken like a creative team might have
taken like who else acts like they know
what they're doing actors and I just
think that was probably the Miss
personally yeah and I'll be clear I
think there were a couple elements of
humor I think that Noggin and goggin
thing was funny I think uh I think the
second frame where he did something I
thought was kind of cute but while I was
watching I like what are we talking
about here and so the thing is it has to
keep your attention and it it didn't
really keep my attention cuz I didn't
know like what this is about and this
was the only ad we've watched so far far
that I had to rewatch to try and
understand and if that's what a lot of
people had to do then they're just never
going to re-watch it and like the
moment's gone all right ad n instacart
let's shoot
it release the hounds Mony baby
[Music]
I'm on a p this the way we take to
the groceries are here thanks babe you
get the
milk I think we're going to have our
first B it's just mid I'll tell you what
I think they did well I'll tell you
things I didn't I didn't like so I think
them showing the actual end result of
using the product which is groceries
delivered immediately and then her
having to go get the cow I think that
was the most compelling part of the ad
the last like four or five seconds which
is good cuz at least it's close to the
CTA or at least is at least telling you
what the company's about in terms of the
the actual ad itself now they probably
they might have been able to do some
sort of co-op with a lot of these Brands
because they're getting you know ads so
they might have all chipped in to to do
this because think about like this if
they help instacart instacart is a
distributor of their products and so if
they help advertise instacart then it
increases the likely that people use
instacart to purchase these things so
I'll bet you that these specific
products will probably see an uptick
among instacart users that being said it
took me a little bit more than a half
second to figure out like what this is
about and I also try to think about this
from the perspective of somebody who
doesn't know what instacart is I know
what instacart is but if you don't know
what instacart is you're like what the
hell is this thing I like a more
tactical uh experience for a customer or
a prospect to understand what problem
this solves I think that's why I think
the last 5 Seconds was compelling like
oh you forgot milk then you know Rush
ordering the milk that was probably the
most Salient use case in the ad and so
if you have the opportunity to
demonstrate that within your own
advertising the problem and then the
immediate solution being your product I
see that as a good thing but I think the
first you know 70% 80% of the ad could
have been better I like the last five or
six seconds so I'll put that as a b all
right add 10 nardis breast cancer
screening I see you again
[Music]
at at look at that you get lift you get
height you get
power your attention please still the
show show how you know I'm going to keep
on dancing so you can keep on gling it
ain't my fault that I was made this
way
[Music]
really let's start paying attention to
breasts when it matters the most early
detection for breast cancer is a game
changer and why I'm able to be here
today so let's get more women screen
than ever before go to your attention
please.com and take the first step big
picture obviously grabbed attention I
mean I I would say 10 out of 10 on the
attention grabbing right like that's
evolutionary and so they obviously
demonstrate that the whole way through I
think that's good they show some pop
culture references they show some
influencers in there show some actors
all that stuff gains attention I'll bet
you people were watching this whole
thing uh all the way through like I was
glued calm down um but you know the tone
shift at the end I think basically you
have a testimonial which is
fundamentally what that is and I do
think there's a decent Jos with the with
the text there I want to give this a B+
I don't think it's an A but I think it's
a B+ I think it was it was an above
average ad so they had you know their
main point and then they had a CTA at
the end I would say the urgencies
implied with the fact that like you
could have something over 6 million
people have this bad thing happen don't
be one of them is kind of the implied
messaging and I think that's good I mean
you could model that ad structure for
just about any business basically tons
of attention fact that Mak someone
uncomfortable testimonial of somebody
who avoided it using the service CTA
like that's fundamentally we just went
through the only lingering question that
I have is like it was so fun I wonder if
it it leaves you feeling good not
feeling like I should go and get my
breast screening and so I think that
it's like this is something that may get
positive accolades obviously cuz who's
going to on a breast cancer ad but
from a purely advertising perspective
the point of advertising is obviously
let people know about your stuff but the
point of persuasion is to change
Behavior right and so I think my larger
question is like how many people
actually go through with it as a result
of this ad compared to maybe an ad that
could have been like I think if they had
done like the Google Gemini version ad
of this where it was like all the
moments you're going to miss out on life
like probably would have been more
compelling second maybe like the Jeep
version of like you know boobs are
Freedom like free the tatas but then all
of a sudden it you know it transitions
here's all the things that boobs are
great for but then it's just like
somebody on a ventilator I think that
would have been more compelling to get
people to like change Behavior so I will
put it as a as a be next one Nike let's
hit
it you can't be demanding you can't be
relentless you can't put yourself first
so put yourself first you can't be
confident so be confident you can't
challenge so challenge you can't
dominate so
dominating you can't Flex so Flex you
can't fill a
stadium so fill that Stadium you can't
be emotional so be emotional you can't
take credit you can't speak up you can't
be so ambitious can't break records
can't have any fun make demands can't
keep scor you can't stand out whatever
you do you can't win
so
when well you know I'm going to be a fan
of uh anything that has just win so
that's that's Alex's life motto more so
that all the difficulties that you go
through can be Rewritten with a W you
know I'm a big fan of winners right
history including your own if you lived
your entire life suffering and then at
the very end you accomplished what you
wanted I think that it would change the
entire narrative there's a great story
that I heard of a guy who was
objectively a failure and they just name
all the failures this guy had and the
one thing he had is he wrote this little
song called Jingle
Bells and so like failed musician failed
at everything but it's
like he won you know what I mean it's
like if all of that was in order to have
this one Timeless thing that ended up
you impacting millions of lives over
over the course of history to me that
sounds like a w so anyways I'm a fan of
Nike's kind of reemergence their new
Direction uh this is obviously a
branding at their whole brand is so wide
in terms of products they sell and they
demonstrate the products across lots of
different sports here they're
associating with each of the people in
there each of the Champions objectively
like they sign goats they sign people
who many consider always the best in the
world and sometimes the best of all time
and so they're associating their brand
with these people whom you like and
they're wearing the product and
demonstrating what it looks like to win
I would say this is a really solid ad
obviously targeted at women um since
it's all female I'll say this this isn't
my favorite Nike ad I'm also not a woman
I'll give this an a you got to put your
hat on for associations they're saying
Nike equals winning and Nike equals
doing what people told you you can't do
and I think that they would probably
want those two associations and Nike
equals all of these great ladies that
you like and that you admire and look up
to therefore to approximate your uh
proximity to them you then buy their
product to feel that way when you put it
on so I think I think it was a
successful you know branding Market and
they're some of the best marketers I
mean if you think about it as a brand
perspective I think Nike is one of the
Premier in terms of their understanding
of of building brand but I'm very happy
that they have come back and talked
about winning again because uh I think
they were touched with a touch of the
the wokeism for a minute there and I'm
just glad they came back to reality Nike
is the the I think is the Roman word for
the goddess of Victory if you're going
to be a brand built on winning it means
there has to be
losers you can't say that everybody's a
winner and then also have a brand that's
about winning cuz if everybody's a
winner no one is that is a quote from
Flash from The Incredibles the cartoon
all right next up rocket morgage this
should be
interesting let's get you
[Music]
home West
Virginia
[Music]
blid
river life is all there older than the
trees younger than the
mountains like a yeah can't wa to get
there man
country
home to
[Applause]
the
m baby home
Country
Road Take Me
Home Country
Road super good ad so they they have
basically I would say a combination of
like three quarters Google Gemini 25%
Jeep and just made it and so
fundamentally let's let's let's walk
through the associations here right I
would say this is an A+ but not s tier
and I'll explain why so let's just walk
through the associations really quickly
so they have what I would call uh
Humanity human moments that many people
associate with and/ Americana all right
which is just basically the American
ethos and so they basically have this
big they they basically build this huge
storyboard of of the American ethos
right the American dream they talk about
the military going home different parts
of the US different Subs segments they
clearly lean a little bit more in the
direction of first-time homeowners at
least that's what I read you know when I
when I look at this ad I think mostly
firsttime homeowners now they may find
out that getting them getting first-time
homeowners then creates the lifetime
value of the customer so that might have
been deliberate I don't know the only
knock I have on this ad is that the CTA
was so short at the end that I didn't
know whose ad it was so basically it's
like they they basically spent the whole
time listing all the things that were
amazing that i'm like I agree with all
of this in the last like 1 second just
it says rocket.com on the screen and I
have to be paying attention to know
rocket.com and to know it's a mortgage
company so that's that's the that's why
this isn't S tier in my opinion like
Google like what separates this from
Google Google I think had the exact same
level of narrative emotionality
sentiment except they were demonstrating
the product throughout the entire ad you
knew it was a Google product they showed
them using it whereas here it was much
more morphous and more difficult to
figure out what it was about I do think
the ad overall though would win the
awards of the feels and only after the
fact people be like oh I love that ad
but they might have now positive
sentiment towards rocket it's possible I
just don't know how many people watched
it was like oh I like this ad but didn't
know who the ad was kind of attributed
to so by and large really strong ad very
and obviously this will only resonate
with people who resonate with the
American dream but if they're
advertising it here during the Super
Bowl Super Bowl is almost as American as
apple pie right it's it's it's the right
time to have an Americana message and I
will say that what the part that I
probably liked the most was they had a
very strong link to the American dream
so they said said own the American dream
and so that was the only like I would
say tie like if we had words own owning
a home I would say that was the the word
that would link all of that to you know
mortgages but otherwise I would say that
it was an A+ not s tier yeah if you like
this kind of like uh breakdown of some
of the brand um I have a whole keynote
on how to reverse engineer and create
your own brand and understand the
elements that create Association how to
strengthen them how to broaden them um
how to gain influence reach um and
ultimately directionality which are the
three elements of brand if you're like I
don't know what that is you definitely
need to watch the video enjoy